Hello and welcome, everyone.
I'm Caro short for Caroline.
I'm a data scientist
at a marketing agency.
I work on a creative tech team.
Basically, that means I
fall down weird rabbit holes
and make cool data toys.
That is not what I'm here
to talk to you about today,
though.
Here, I am going
to talk about why
we should talk about people who
think they are not data people.
Back in 2020, we all kind
of became armchair experts
sitting there pondering
in our living rooms
because we couldn't
go anywhere else.
If you were thinking
of COVID, you and I
are thinking of the
exact same thing.
All of a sudden there was all
this new jargon that came out.
All these charts, all these
numbers, all these stats,
case counts.
Flatten the curve
was super popular,
and if you didn't know what
flattening the curve meant,
you just pretended like you
did so that you could keep up
with everyone else.
But everyone was
all of a sudden--
like our lives were
up front and personal with data.
It would say whether or not
we should go out, whether or not
we should see people. Depending
on the case counts,
would determine,
should we wear a mask?
Should we see our friends?
Should we stay inside
and do absolutely nothing
else but bake sourdough bread?
Really,
data became very, very
up close and personal.
And data have always been
there in the background,
but it hasn't
always been obvious.
And so in this, I kind
of had this realization
that not everyone
is interpreting
data in the same way
that I interpret data.
And there was a lot
of misconceptions
that this brought up for me.
So that's kind of what
has inspired this.
I want to get started
with this quote,
because maybe you're sitting
out there thinking, I mean,
I know something
about data, but like,
do I really have
anything to share?
Yes, you do.
As we become more and
more expert in our field,
we kind of forget that
not everyone is directly
behind us following us
down that rabbit hole.
And so it's worthwhile
to look around, remember
our blind spots, and to be able
to share with those around us.
So those misconceptions I
was talking about with COVID,
a lot of people tend to think
data are just charts or just
a bunch of numbers or charts
with stuff and more stuff.
And it's just kind of this
thing that maybe you just think
about a lot, or maybe
it's really scary
and data is taking
over, or maybe data
is just for the nerds.
Like, that's it.
It's hard.
We don't need to think about it.
And my response to
these things is, Yes
and. Yes data are all of those
things on the previous slide
and so much more.
In improv comedy,
there's this theory of
Yes and that you take what
your partner has given you.
You take the setting, the
characters, maybe the setup,
and you add to it.
You say Yes and you
add something new.
So I'm going to say
Yes to all of the data
things on the previous slide.
And then also add
something new here.
So we're meeting people
with where they're at
and where they're coming from.
So yes, to all the things,
and data is creative.
It's not always black and white.
There's a lot of gray.
Doesn't always have
the right answers,
which maybe is a terrifying
thing for you to think about.
But it's also super scientific.
It helps us interpret
the world around us
and understand information
so that we can better
understand the world that
we live in and ourselves.
And then as you
look around, data
are everywhere, which
makes it really fun,
at least in my opinion, to
talk about data because they're
all over the place.
You can ask my
friends and family.
They think they've had way too
many of these conversations.
I say never enough.
But it's everywhere.
So, with that in mind,
you're all formally
invited to a data party.
Yes, I realize we are
already at a data party.
We're at RStudio conf.
So here's yet another
data party invite.
But this one is
just about talking
about data wherever,
whenever, because it's cool
and obviously with
a lot of excitement.
If you see, I'm very excited.
It's not hard to get me
excited about this stuff.
So let's hop into
this invitation
of what's really going on
behind this data party.
You might have noticed.
So who are we talking about?
You might have noticed,
I throw quotes around non datas
a lot. Like, I'm a data person
or I'm a non data person.
This is intentional.
Usually I think this is
a self designated term
to be a data person
or a non data person.
But really everyone
is a data person.
We just exist somewhere
on this spectrum.
So maybe you think
you're closer to novice,
maybe you think you're
closer to expert.
Honestly, any of those
is good and valid.
It just matters that we
all recognize we all exist
somewhere on this spectrum,
and we can meet people
with where they're at.
I also want to point out that
the line from novice to expert
is probably not straight, so
don't think it's that easy.
There's usually a lot of
rabbit holes, a lot of twists
and turns along the
way, and there's also
a lot of different
end paths for expert.
It doesn't mean that we
will necessarily all end
at the same place,
which is why it's
good to remember we all have
blind spots. To look around,
think of what you
see, what you know,
and realize that people
might be on different paths
and it's worthwhile
sharing things.
So when you're looking
around for people
to talk to about data,
maybe it could be anyone.
If you're working in
an org, maybe it's
someone who doesn't
work on your team,
or it's a team that you
work with more obliquely.
So now that we know who
we should be looking for,
who we should be
talking to, what
should we talk to them about?
Data but that's a
very broad category.
So I'm going to give you
some more specific things
to think about.
So since we're meeting
people where they're at,
we're saying Yes and we're
taking their data knowledge
and then adding something to it.
What can we add to it?
I like to think about this
in terms of a grid axis.
It's how I organize my
brain anyways. So we
can move from less
technical to more technical,
personal to general.
Let's think about
this in terms of music
to give some practical
examples, because what
could be educational,
it could be interesting,
it could be a variety of
things, but this is how
we're going to break it down.
So if we keep it really not too
technical and very personal,
we can think of Spotify Wrapped
in that lower left quarter
Spotify Wrapped.
You've probably heard of it.
It's the end of year
thing where it's
like you listened to this
many Spotify artists,
you listened to this
many playlists.
This was your top five songs.
It's pretty cool.
It's pretty fun.
But at the end of the
day, it's just counting.
It's like, how many times
did you listen to this song?
So pretty simple
data underlying it,
although it is for
your personal music,
so it's fun to see how yours
is different from your friends.
If we're looking for
something still not
too technical, but
more general, Music
Borders is a really
interesting article put out
by The Pudding, which
if you hadn't haven't
heard of The Pudding, I highly
recommend you check them out.
It's a very interesting
data journalism
outlet that's very fun and
interesting rabbit holes.
This Music Borders
looks at what is
the most popular
song in your city
or your state or your
country, and then you
can compare all
around the world.
So what you think
is super popular
and that hit song people
may have never heard
about on the other
side of the world.
And they could be listening to
something entirely different,
which is super fun
to think about as how
music can connect
us and be different,
but also a unifying thing.
And then if we're
looking more technical,
if we really want to go
into the weeds with someone
on some data, maybe we look
at Nadieh Bremer's data art
that pulls in a lot of
different pieces of data
into a visualization that
really pulls together
some interesting things.
And we can talk about
what goes into a good data
visualization? What
data pieces make
something really interesting
or really unique,
and look at that?
And then, if we want to go
super technical, The Pudding also
has this really fun thing
that will rant and rave
about your Spotify or your
Apple Music streaming.
It is hilarious, but
under the hood is an AI.
So you could go deep in
the weeds with someone
explaining an AI,
what goes into that?
What kind of data are
collected and really
go deeper with someone on that.
So now that we
know some examples
of what we might be thinking
about as we're presenting,
where and when should we
be talking to these people?
So if we're talking
something more technical,
it's probably worthwhile
to maybe set up
an invite with someone,
put it on their calendar
so they know it's coming, and
so they can mentally prepare,
get excited, maybe send some
documentation in advance.
Really set up for success
for this conversation.
Other times, maybe it's
a more casual thing
and you're hanging out
at a cocktail party
and you're able
to just small talk
away whatever latest data viz
floated by in your Twitter
that was really
interesting that day.
So thinking about where and
when should we have these data
conversations with
folks really depends
on the what.
What are we talking about?
Who are we talking
to and at what
level do we need to meet them?
Why are we having this party?
Let's remember why we're even
going to go through this.
So as we had these
misconceptions at the beginning
or different
conceptions of data.
Data are science plus art. It's
the things the two together.
Data are also an
accessibility tool.
I'll give you an example.
Let's say, I want to
learn about penguins.
I could go to the Antarctic
and stare at penguins all day.
I would probably learn
a lot about penguins
and see some interesting things.
I would also be very
cold and probably bored,
if I'm being honest.
Slash I have other things I
want to do in my life,
so I will leave the counting
of penguins up to the people
who get super pumped
about penguins.
But in that, I can
take their data
and look at it in
different ways.
So maybe I will look at their
data and read it in a book
or in some text like this
and see cool longest flipper
length of this penguin is this.
Maybe I would summarize
the data in a table
and just have the
summary stats like that.
Maybe have a little
bit less context.
But I still see the
data in some way.
Or maybe I see data as
a chart and all three
of these show the same
kinds of data, but in three
different ways, which is
super important because data
themselves summarize information
so that we can understand
the world around us and we
can present in different ways.
Data viz and
accessibility in charts
is a whole other conversation.
I could probably make
this chart better.
I could probably make it
much worse to be accessible.
But it's interesting to think
about how we can show data
and what we can learn
from each of these.
Because you learn
different things,
or you might realize
different things
by looking at the exact same
data in a different way.
This is also super
important because we're
not always talking
about penguins,
although we might want to.
This also matters because
when we're in our daily lives
and we have news feeds come
up with different stats
or different charts, we want
to be able to understand those
and we want others to be able
to understand them and realize,
what do I need to be
understanding about this chart?
What is the key
piece of information
I need out of this graph?
And then also to realize, is
this chart leading me astray?
Could this be fake news?
And being able to realize when
a chart might be misleading
is a very important
skill to have.
And so by introducing people
to some simpler concepts
or to even have
these conversations
allows people to realize and be
able to understand data better
in their daily lives
as they go about them.
So maybe you are
totally ready to get out
there, to go for it, to
start talking about data,
and you are pumped.
If that is the case,
go forth, do it.
I fully support you. But maybe
you want some more resources.
Maybe you need to sign
up for a newsletter.
There's some that will send out
a chart weekly, break it down
for you and make it
really interesting.
You can listen to a
podcast, read a book.
This is one of my
favorite books.
You Look Like a Thing and I
Love You by Janelle Shane, it is.
I'm getting some head nods.
It's a hilarious book.
It's all about AI. The title
is a pickup line written
by AI. So I feel like
that should say enough
for why you should go
read this or just use
that on your next thing.
You look like a
thing and I love you.
Try it out and let me
know how that goes.
I would love to hear
it. But really, this
is just to prepare
you to give you
some thoughts of what to
talk about when you're
talking with people about data.
And my best advice is really
just go out there and do it.
It might feel super awkward and
super weird at the beginning
and people might give
you some weird looks.
Embrace it.
Data is super exciting and
we just need to jump in.
So for this last thing, I
want to close on a story.
So back in 2020, the first
week of working from home,
I was super inspired by
Georgia Lupi's data portraits.
I thought, this
is super awesome.
I want to do the exact
same thing for my team.
What a fun thing to
have on our desks when
we go back to the office
like a little name
plate, a little fun
welcome back
thing. Spoiler,
we never went back
to the office.
So I still made them though.
And it was super fun.
I made them.
We talked about them.
It was super fun to have
people guess who was who
because I just showed
them this screen.
And I was like, guess
which one you are?
Some people got it.
Some people didn't.
It was fun.
All right.
But it was an interesting
way that we could talk about,
within our data team, to
learn how can we best support
each other while we're
all working remote?
How do we best work remote?
And having those conversations
in a way that maybe you
don't typically have.
It wasn't like forced by HR,
but it was this fun, creative,
data driven way.
Additionally, our creative lead
caught wind of this project.
And he's like,
hey, Caro, I heard
you did some cool data thing.
And I was like, Yes.
And he's like, I'm going
to have you present that
to the entire creative team.
And I was like, really?
OK. At the time, I was working
on a team that did primarily
like your classic
marketing analytics,
meaning how many people
clicked on this email?
How many people should
we target on Twitter?
How should we set up our
tagging specification?
So kind of the bookends of a
project, like we'd help set it up
and then we report on it after.
By presenting this project
to our creative team
that were mostly
what they would self designate
themselves as non data people.
It blew their minds
that data could be this
creative, this interesting,
this innovative.
And it was really
interesting for me
also because then I got to
have all these conversations
after the fact with people about
how can we incorporate data
in new and innovative
ways that we
hadn't considered incorporating
into our projects previously.
And it was really interesting
because we were able
when you're able to let
data out of the box,
to let your creative side and
your data side work together,
we can do so many
cool things with data.
We can do interesting projects
and change the way that we
perceive the world around us.
So getting back to
the point of why is it
beneficial for us data people to
talk to these non data people?
One, it's good to
help them understand
the world around them
so they can interpret charts.
That's all fine and good.
It is also good for us
because then selfishly
we get to work on cooler stuff.
If people are also
pumped about data and we
ourselves are
enthusiastic about it,
then we are able to bring these
passions together to share them
and to do really cool things.
So thank you.
Thank you for coming
to my data party.
I encourage you to
go start your own.